if you stay in your comfort zone that's
why you will fail you will fail in your
comfort zone stop trying to be something
you ain't gifted at I lost everything I
became homeless I lived in a car for
three years I need motivation we believe
nation
please Steve Harvey and here's my take
on this top ten success vol 3
enjoy what you gotta do to get the life
that God wants you to have you got to
put more air in your bubble you got to
blow your bubble up expand yourself take
yourself out your comfort zone do not
live in your bubble put some more air in
your bubble if you stay in your comfort
zone that's where you will fail you will
fail in your comfort zone success is not
a comfortable procedure it is a very
uncomfortable thing to attempt so you
got to get comfortable being
uncomfortable if you ever want to be
successful start putting some pressure
on put some pressure on yourself get out
here and get about it look I'd love to
sugarcoat this thing for you I'd like to
tell you if you go out here and get rich
do a couple of things damn they happen
you got get real doggish you gotta get
downright funky if you want to make it
now like I was telling you before if you
want to be ordinary you ain't even got
to listen to me
just go about your business if you think
ordinary is cool ain't no problem it's
some really really wonderful ordinary
people but if you are sitting in this
room and you have extraordinary
aspirations then you don't have to do
extra you put extra on top of
extraordinary and you come up with
extraordinary it's no other way I'm
sorry but here's the fact all of you
have extraordinary capabilities all of
you you have to decide if you are
willing to do the things to put you in
that category rich people don't sleep
eight hours a day that's a third of your
life in April 24 hours in a day you
cannot be sleep eight hours a day
you can't live in
late and wake up at 8 o'clock in the
morning it's 11 o'clock on the East
Coast the stock market been open two
hours they already make a decisions
about your life and your ass will sleep
rule number two follow you're just not
your passion quit running away from the
gift your gift will make room for you
stop trying to be something you ain't
gifted at nobody asked you to go around
here study to be a dentist and you're a
really good at that
quit going down to the church trying to
sing you can't say that just cuz they
let you sing at the church you're not
feeling everybody else here to go with
this because you know come-as-you-are
the lord loveth a cheerful Giver all
that we don't apply scriptures out here
you come to the Apollo and you can't say
we got something for your ass up there
period listen to me all of you have this
guilt identified it's the thing that you
do the absolute best with the least
amount of effort that's what you should
be doing you're wasting your time
pursuing your passion the bible does not
mention passion it mentions your gift
what are you gifted at and do that stop
trippin you can do that if you fried
chicken better than everybody you know
you all be somewhere fried chicken rule
number three jump
okay here's a deal if you want to be
successful here's the thing you have to
do you have to jump there is no way
around you have to jump every successful
person has jumped you got to jump you
got to take a leap of faith
you got to dash off that cliff and you
got to jump out there as far as you can
now a lot of times you stand on the
cliff of life and you see other people
soaring by glide and down like a bird
and fly through the air you know they go
on over to the South of France
you see them on boat somewhere you see
their family vacation in here and a
family vacation to that you see them
dressing like this you see him in New
York then you see him in London a fine
bye you know why it's because the
impression on me but the only way to get
your passion to open so he could saw you
got the job now it is a problem here's
the problem my friends when you jump I
can assure you one thing you listening I
promise you this your parachute will not
hopefully right away no that's the fatal
flaw I promise you your parachute will
not open right away you're gonna hit
them sides in the rocks you want to
carry your back out a little cliff
you're gonna you don't cut yourself
you're gonna get mourn again
you're gonna get some tans and stuff
like that but it virtually past should
will home and you'll be soft but here's
the other caveat let me teach you this
right here if you do not jump I promise
you want that your passion will never
hold so you say to another soul you got
the jump rule number four make a vision
board who do not understand this if you
do not have it written down your chances
of it happening is reduced drastically
because it's a principle of success you
have to have everything you want written
it's in the Bible
now you ain't got to be the greatest
Christian in the world you still got to
get some of these scriptures on a pile
Rebecca - and - it says write the vision
and make it plain so that he who reads
it will run to it and even though it
tarry that mean take a long time wait
for it
for surely you will come at an appointed
time that's in the Bible
listen to me that's real if you don't
think is real I dare you to try it
write everything you want on a piece of
paper everything I don't care
use your wildest imagination if you can
think it you can achieve it write it on
a piece of paper read it every morning
and every night come back here one year
from today and see how much of that
stuff then came true that's a promise of
yo God
that ain't no Theory I come up with
that's all successful people having
Oprah's on TV for 30 years telling
people our vision board it's very real
you have to write it if it's not written
you reduce your chances greatly of it
ever occurred also if you want to see
what Steve Harvey and other black
entrepreneurs have to say about
excellence check out by 2:54 series the
link is in the description below failure
means you've now learned another
valuable lesson that pushes you one step
closer to success your gift can be
anything you can't look at it as simply
running jumping singing and dancing rule
number five expose yourself to better
things
Google success see if you get it Google
exposure see if you get it you have to
be exposed to certain things in order
for you to know it and success is hard
if I could get I try to give my
Millennials to understand it take a long
time to make a lot of money daddy you
making money you did I'm 61 it take a
long time to make a lot of money you
can't just go make money because you got
Google let me show you something when
you get on the airplane you ever noticed
when you walk on the airplane you walk
past first class everybody in first
class got gray hair you ever noticed
that they all a little up in age they
all 50 and up especially doing the week
businessman they earn the right you go
in the back it's young people back there
you back there
you got your iPhone out you got your
headsets on them grown-ass men okay I
got they lay across they got a briefcase
out there trying to figure now they
trying to make this paper they in front
but you've got to be exposed to get to
first class you got to be successful to
get to first class that's why they close
that curtain see they can't have your
ass in bracket at playing with that
curtain open you ain't gonna believe
what's going on up there
they bring in a hot wash cloth you can
wash up they given up passing out menus
everybody get hot nuts you get all you
want to drink you ain't got to pay for
the headsets you get to watch the movies
free you get a choice of what you want
to eat
they gotta close that curtain if you was
in the back and they left that curtain
on you're driving people crazy
hey what my nuts you don't get no nuts
how come I just got a half a can of coke
that's all we giving you how come meat
drinks is fired on he didn't order three
drinks because he paid for first-class
the seats is wider your knees can't
touch the seat in front of you it can't
the overhead space is plentiful for
everybody that's why they closed the
curtain so what you have to do you have
to expose yourself to things early in
life this is my suggestion do whatever
you got to do to upgrade to first class
if you spend a little bit more money
it's sometime when you buy the coach
ticket when you get it to counter just
ask them how much is an upgrade if they
say $75 just pay it one time what
happens is once you sit in that
first-class seat you have now been
exposed the game changes now when you
see that there's actually room on each
side of you in first-class when you
discover that you can slouch in your
seat that your
does not have to touch the other
person's on that they're gonna bring you
a hot tile they're gonna get you a menu
they're gonna let you drink all you want
you ain't got to buy the hair says once
you fly first-class it conditions your
mind to look and think for first-class
opportunities once you fly first-class
let me explain something to you
walking past first-class gonna be hard
once you then set up there flew a couple
hours in first-class walking past them
seats will be the hardest walk you make
because you've been exposed rule number
six don't give up your attitude
determines your altitude if you're a
positive person positive things happen
to you if you're a negative person
negative things are going to continue to
happen for you if you can put that in
your scope this year just change your
attitude wake up and smile how about
just wake up and be grateful it's just
it's just common sense right next thing
especially after a show like today life
is really 10% what happens to you and
90% what you do about it look everybody
in this room everybody watch it
everybody got something they got to deal
with get to dealing with it stop
complaining about it complaining about
it only makes it stay present do
something about it so life is 10% what
happens to you is 90% what you do about
and finally don't give up when reaching
your dream is difficult
listen if success were easy you've heard
it a million times everybody would be
successful it requires a grit and a
toughness to be successful but I got
news for you it's something that all of
you have in you
now whatever you've been through
whatever that is guess what you still
here you know what that makes you a
pretty tough first rule number seven
take risks I was 27 years old October
8th 1985 hilarities
walked in the comedy club first time in
my life
one amateur night $50 drove 40 minutes
home cried all the way home this girl I
wrote what she said why are you crying a
nimble $50 is your name understand
I'm born she said what you mean you born
I said I know what I'm gonna do the rest
of my life she said you ain't wearing a
$50 but now I've been praying my whole
life God what is it my life got to be
more than this I wanted that comedy
competition I went to work October 9th
the next morning and quit my job I'm
gonna tell you something that decision
cost me everything I had I lost
everything I lost my family I lost
friends I lost every day I became
homeless I lived in a car for three
years but I just saw this I saw this I
saw this vision I just pursued it I said
why that's it you have to take chances
in life if you don't take chances in
life you'll never have the life God has
for you life is about risk if you play
it safe in life you ain't gonna have
much of a life if you play it safe you
won't have much of a life life is risk
it take it take courage to pursue your
dream rule number eight slow down I look
back at myself sometime and I think what
advice
what would I tell that young guy in
college who was on the verge of flunking
out of that very same College what would
I tell myself well I tell myself about
forgiveness I remind myself I would
teach myself to forgive a lot quicker
including myself I held myself to my own
pain for a long time because I kept
rehashing those failures over and over
and over again and in rehashing those
failures it prevented me from moving
forward so I would tell that
twenty-year-old guy back then be a
little bit more forgiving of yourself
and a whole lot more forgiving of other
people's to remember that Lord's Prayer
that your mama taught you forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us
it would have made my way a lot easier I
would also tell myself to slow down a
little bit don't go so fast what you're
rushing for life is coming see every
time you rush you get ahead you missed
some steps
I missed a lot of steps in life but if
you noticed every time you missed a step
in life you gotta go back and get on
that step rule number nine
just be you I can't tell you about no
education cuz I ain't got one
I ain't got no degree in nothing I've
been told my whole life you'll never be
nun simply because of the way you talk
you know many times I've been the way I
talk man cuz you know I'm kind of
country all really I don't really speak
that good you know my my English isn't
that eloquent I know that but I never
let that stop me when I first got on TV
at NBC seven years ago they sent her off
then a linguist to see me I didn't even
know what that was I thought this lady
was gonna show me how to make spaghetti
or something I didn't know I've never
heard what is the linguist so the woman
comes in my office she says are you
ready to begin and I said excuse me
ma'am who are you
she says I'm your grammar coach I said
for what she said NBC is under the
understanding in order for you to be
successful on daytime TV
you're gonna have to learn how to speak
more eloquently I said I even do all
that there she said excuse me what did
you just say I said I'm gonna do all
that there she said say what you just
said to me again slowly I said I ain't
Fidler dude all let there she said
that's exactly why I'm here
because that is improper grammar on
every level I say yeah but that's how I
talk just like this Hill she said say
that again
I saw a table just like this Hill she
said slow that down I say I talk just
like this hill
what's the problem she said if you don't
learn how to speak more properly you'll
never be successful
I said who told you that you walked into
my office I'm already on TV you know
what were you trying to go with this see
the reason I'm not gonna let you change
my mind is cuz I've never known you open
to this point now I made it to this
point without you I don't know how you
figure I'm gonna get the rest of the way
without you so I'm just looking at this
lady she says listen to me if you don't
learn how to speak better you'll be off
TV I said okay let me ask you so I said
which one of these sound best to you I
am broke or army is rich and rule number
10 the last 24 a very special bonus clip
is half size though
you don't see these a lot in the hood
but
see that okay don't know don't move
Steve just sit real still I'm gonna show
you this guy now this guy is named Tonka
Steve and this guy this guy he doesn't
mess around
he's an alligator snapping turtle this
is about 150 year old Turtles like a
living dinosaur up to 1,500 pounds of
pressure in that mouth so if something
comes down on it BAM smashes in a
thousand pieces you might seem smash
something yeah grab that carrot it's
about to get real in here Steve
it'll give you street cred now they can
about know Street create yeah you know
what Steve ain't doing none of this ill
man
let me try could be the one time he
develop one let me show what they do hey
man you gonna keep all he'll keep all
and it's got shiny I don't know what
they told you about me this guy say this
is a fish right fish comes in he's like
oh look at that food up there it goes in
there that's what I'm talkin about Steve
[Applause]
you see that this guy you don't mess
around you old as hell and daddy used to
look I've got a special bonus tip from
Steve Harvey on how to immerse yourself
in success that I really think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
time to move from just watching videos
taking action in your life for business
here we go question number one what is
the risk that you've been putting off
that you need to take number two what
are you gonna put on your vision board
and number three what will you do this
week to get outside your comfort zone
you have to get fluent in the language
of success so you speak it with ease
surround yourself with people who've
accomplished their dreams and immerse
yourself in the culture of achievement
and before you know it you've gotta be
speaking the life of your dreams and to
existence and like I've said before we
each have a gift but too many people
miss out because they refuse to sign the
lease on their gift you keep looking for
it outside of you stop sit with yourself
what is it that you do the absolute best
with the least amount of effort that's
your gift but if you are constantly
looking outside of yourself and you
don't latch on to your gift you will
never find your purpose if you want to
succeed you must commit to your own gift
and
SiC
and if you want more CFR we check out
the first top 10 rules video and have
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there the dream
is free the hustle the soul I aim for
stuff so big that the dream is bigger
than the fear